c'est ma surprise c'est donc super
derniers jours de travail avant le
déclenchement des élections
karine ne vallières reçoit un cadeau
inusité de la part d'artistes de sa
région
une reproduction grand format de son
logo de député
si je met à boire mais chez nous on
enlève les chances des boîtes ce passage
branle bas de combat au bureau mais
aussi à la maison
karine vallières emménage dans une
nouvelle résidence pour se rapprocher de
ses deux filles les filles savent hommes
sont en large panache f consiste à
relier après six ans de va et vient
constant entre l'assemblée nationale et
sa circonscription et de travail presque
ses jours sur 7
le changement de vie sera radical dans
la perspective d'être réélu est ce que
pendant quatre ans je suis capable de
façon personnelle avec ma vie familiale
ce qui se déroule en ce moment est ce
que je suis capable de maintenir ce
rythme là karine vallières peut compter
sur l'avis d'un expert pour la
décoration du salon mais surtout en
politique son père yvon vallières
vétérans de l'assemblée nationale a été
député pendant 34 ans membre du
gouvernement de robert bourassa et de
jean charest il connaît la difficulté de
concilier la vie de famille avec celle
de député dans les comtés ruraux plus
particulièrement où c'est le séjour de
longue date alors un jour une autre
donnée entre la politique et puis la
panne et j'ai eu deux concerts j'avais
déjà mentionné très ouvertement aussi
que j'avais des problèmes de santé
mentale j'avais j'ai fait une dépression
majeure
très peu de temps avant de me présenter
en 2012 en plus ça forge qui on est tout
simplement elles mêmes a passé son passé
puis on veut la vivre peut-être encore
plus intensément par contre après est-ce
que vous rendez compte que je veux
sortir ma valise maintenant pour des
événements heureux comme voyage et non
pas pour partir à chaque semaine avec le
temps karine vallières a compris qu'il
faisait vivre à ses filles
ce qu'elle avait vécu plus jeunes comme
enfin de député et on est de moins en
moins là on reconnaît de moins en moins
leurs intérêts elles l ont de moins en
moins envie de te parler un moment donné
comme parrain pl c'est là que tu te
rends compte que ce temps c'est
inévitable que t'es trop absente
élu pour la première fois en 2012 la
députée de 34 ans a d'abord été porte
parole de l'opposition en matière de
lutte à la pauvreté puis whip adjointe
du gouvernement couillard en 2014 et
adjointe parlementaire du premier
ministre pour la jeunesse beaucoup de
temps pour les autres très peu pour elle
quelle crise karine vallières veut
maintenant se rattraper surtout auprès
de ses filles elle le fait avec
application en ces jours de rentrée
scolaire
pour moi ce moment à l'heure où le plus
important que jusqu'à toujours le rôle
de mère puis après on verra
qu'est-ce qui vous ont été filmées
quelque chose mais c'est marrant comme
ça semble plus que deux minutes avec
maman est les six dernières années cinq
soirs et auront plus qu elle devienne je
pense fait un choix qui très vite réagi
et puis câline le cac40 air alors était
encore trop jeune
quand les filles sont ce marché du
travail qui sait peut-être à nouveau la
police et le choix
à l'aube de la quarantaine karine de
vallières est maintenant à la recherche
d'un nouvel emploi et de nouvel
équilibre j'ai adoré ce que j'essaie de
travailler avec la communauté de
travailler pour leur bien ça me fait le
plus grand bien juste à mal ce qui est
certain c'est qu'elle ne s'impliquera
pas dans la campagne électorale actuelle
mais la suite n'est pas encore écrite
parce que j'ai pris la bonne décision
quand avec mes enfants j'ai su que oui
mais je peux pas dire que ça va pas
manquer
[Musique]